[Music]
the first season i had a major crush on
jen um and i remember
saying one time to david it's gonna be
such a bummer if the first time
you and i actually kiss is gonna be on
national
television sure enough
first time we kissed was in that coffee
shop
[Music]
but it was like two ships passing
because
one of us was always in a relationship
so
and we never crossed that boundary
[Laughter]
the friends dropped a bombshell ross and
rachel almost became a thing
in real life jen also talked about her
ex brad pitt
who guest starred on the show the year
after their 2000 wedding
fella yes yes pit came did one
rachel dream
16 years after their split a source
tells e.t the friendly exes
respect each other and think each other
is wildly talented and hilarious
adding there's nothing romantic there
but they are
definitely aware that their fans are
constantly rooting for them to get back
together
another revelation matthew perry's major
anxiety
i felt like i was gonna die if they
didn't laugh
and it's not healthy for sure but i
would sometimes say a line and they
wouldn't laugh and i would
sweat and and just like
go into convulsions if i didn't get the
laugh i was supposed to get i would it
would take you down
you didn't tell us that would you would
no i don't remember you ever saying that
oh yeah and this was awkward when the
cast talked about how they all stayed in
touch
the actor joked i don't hear from anyone
there were also concerns that matthew
who has been open about his past
struggle with addiction
was slurring his words i can still hear
the screaming
some fans worried the 51 year old had a
stroke but a uk tabloid claimed
matthew had emergency dental surgery the
morning of the taping
as for the show's big surprises smelly
cats
melody cat what are they feeding you
lady gaga in a gospel choir join lisa
kudrow for smelly cat
i still think it's better when it's just
me cindy crawford modeled ross's leather
pants
justin bieber donned a potato suit to
recreate ross's halloween costume
spudnik and even e.t was a part of the
friends reunion that's streaming now on
hbo max
here i am on the set of friends in
monica and chandler's apartment where in
just
hours the show that made tv must see
must end this will be the last time that
we're ever asked about the show as a
group
that we will do this like we're not
going to do this again in 15 more years
i'm really thankful and i love you guys
so much i love you so much
one more incredible thing about this
reunion they reportedly each got 2
million dollars for it oh it's not done
there because they also get two percent
of the show's syndication
that's 20 million dollars a year each